thanks everyone for coming to listen to
this talk my name is in houston i'm
going to talk a little bit about python
on cloud foundry and and yet thank you
very much to to james and there and all
the organizers for putting on such a
great conference i'm really excited to
be able to speak here and i was actually
here at the New York PI data conference
last year and it's great to see it's
keeping going and it's expanded so far
around the world there's even one in
London now she will talk about in a
minute and but who am I so my Twitter
account isn't there I just tweeted a
link which is actually at the bottom
about which is collecting a lot of the
resources for this talk so code and
there's a video as well to show later
and just some you know further reading
for you if you want to get an interested
in how to do this kind of thing and my
github account is there and but me
myself I'm a data scientist i work at
pivotal and i use the PI data stack day
to day for predictive analytics and
machine learning before that i was
actually a theoretical physicist so I
was actually using Python for high
performance computing and numerical
simulations using things like Sun great
engine and clusters and all that sort of
thing as well before i get into Clyburn
we just want it yet quickly shade age
about PI data London and this is a
meetup group that was started after the
first PI data London conference and
we've been hosting it at pivotal for the
last six months and but they've grown so
large they're going from zero to seven
hundred plus members since May and the
organizer in Oswald likes to tell James
Powell that it's actually the fastest
growing Python data meet up and not the
biggest yet but we're growing fastest
and the next London conference is
actually already being sort of arranged
in it actually going to be in june next
year so if anyone's in Europe or in
London and try and head to that actually
this is a picture taken in our offices
when the world cup was on that's why
there's all english flags they are in
the foreground today that i'm going to
talk about side foundry and in
particular I want to talk about Python
on side foundry how many people have
actually heard of type foundry before
whew so safe andrea is an open source
cloud platform or platform as a service
suppose people describe it as the idea
is that it's a simple way for developers
to deploy applications scale them and
make them highly available for the
backend people it sort of AB takes away
all the hassle of spinning up servers or
spinning up you know the config for
Apache or the load balancing etc and
tries to like make that whole process
extremely easy and the idea is that it
also enables you to be cloud independent
somewhat so you don't get locked in
maybe to Amazon Web Services or Google
compute engine or Microsoft Azure and
have like that kind of cost of ever
having to move from one of those to
another one if say the prices go up or
you know the whole system goes down like
Ezra did last week so it said Cloud
Foundry is an open source platform was
first developed at VMware and then
became part of pivotal when pivotal
started last year and we're still
leaving the open source development but
we've actually got quite a lot of
partners involved now in developing the
open source project and we're building
this cloud foundry foundation which is I
suppose sort of a similar idea to you
know the Python software foundation or
the Apache foundation and it's basically
a governing body that helps direct the
the development and promotion of Cloud
Foundry all these big names are involved
you know IBM HP SI p and some further
people down there interesting canonical
is on there and in fact click foundry
ships with a bunch of server now so it's
actually you know becoming quite a big
part of the stack one slide overview of
Cloud Foundry for developers and data
scientists would be this so if I have a
directory or app in a directory and want
to push it i won't actually deploy it
into real live web site all i have to do
is CF push i don't need to go and you
know install apache go install whatever
you know python interpreter go install
all my packages all i need to do is do
see I've pushing it the system actually
takes care of everything itself it does
some introspection it goes finds what
your package needs and sets it all up
for you sets up some saying defaults for
things like load balancing and and you
can take advantage of that by scaling up
your app so
you can go from one instance to five
instances just with a straight forward
command you can change the memory
allocation the disk allocation etc an
interesting thing for in the data
science and data people is you can
actually bind data services into your
application and so we have you know I'll
talk a little bit later about all the
different types of data services but
things like Redis RabbitMQ Cassandra
those kind of things you can spin those
up start them and then connect them into
your little app and without actually
most much hassle in the back end you
don't need to go off and install
Cassandra yourself and do all that music
so for data scientists I think it's like
a Productivity booster and you know I
find myself often having to just make
little you know single web page apps and
to display results or to show customers
something I've done and and if I needed
to go and like try and a in the old days
I suppose provision a server set it all
up but in five days go to AWS spin
something up there i use the management
console do all that and it just takes a
little bit more time so this is actually
just really quick and simple way of
doing this for like this sort of
enterprise people who've had to you know
do this over there hundreds of servers
that they may have internally this is
kind of the big difference you know you
go from having to set up everything in
50 configuration touches to set up your
domain name set up the load balancing
set up apache the way you want you know
whatever you need to do and now you just
actually do do one kind of really
straightforward configuration in the
back end so I think the example that
they give one that when they talk about
this to large industries enterprises
Morgan Stanley who have by 20 full-time
engineers just maintaining and deploying
tomcat servers throughout the
organization just finding tomcat servers
you know updating them keeping them you
know the configs right and refreshing
them and installing them and doing all
that kind of thing but I want kind of
want to talk about Python and cloud
foundry and pythons actually at first
class language and along with some
others like go Ruby and java and nodejs
and even PHP for some reason and and the
official sort of system actually
automatically detects if you have a
Python application so you didn't know
don't need to tell ty founder you've
written a Python app it'll actually go
and do things like it looks for
and stop txt file for example or it
looks for py extensions in your
directory and it will decide okay this
is a patent application what do I need
to do so what it does is it goes in
stores are quite an interpreter for you
it goes users pip to install any of your
dependencies and then it starts the
application as requested so you can
either put in you know if you're using
flask say which i'm going to show you
later you can just put in python my apt
pie or whatever and that's how the
server will be started you can do lots
of other things as well if you want to
okay so i wanted to show what it's
simple has everyone use flask before or
they kind of know the idea it's kind of
a very simple as sort of i suppose low
footprint python web server and you can
just you know make a web app in a few
like five or ten lines and that just
serves a page whatever i just want to
show how easy it is to actually do that
in Cloud Foundry I think because the
Wi-Fi wasn't working up here I'm going
to do this as a video and so you can see
it so I'm just going to talk to you this
is on youtube so you can actually go
look at it later so these are the files
i have in my app this is the flask app
really straightforward the one thing
here is i have to find the port so type
foundry tells me the porsche in this
environmental variable and and then I
just tell flask to start with that
Porsche crime and stop text is just
flask and then there's this proc file or
a manifest file just tells you how to
start the app so Python hello duck pie
in this case and then I said it just CF
push and just give your app a name here
and and what it'll do is first of all
upload you know i'm logged into this
environment here is pivotal data science
environment it goes it creates a domain
name for you just automatically based on
your app name or you can tell it what to
my name you want uploads the application
which is here just for files and then it
goes to try and start this so it figures
out ok what do I need right I need a
Python application so i need to install
an interpreter i need to install with
pitbull the requirements goes and does
that you can see it installing things
like flask and ginger and and then it
has put all of this into a container
these aren't quite yet docker container
is actually something different i can
talk about that later but it's built a
container and then it goes and starts
the application and then it's
and here we can see the URL you can see
the state down there it's using like 50
megabytes of memory at the moment and I
can go and see that the application is
actually running it's a very simple web
after them just as hello world we can
actually go back and then scale up as I
said so scallops a 25 instances and and
it's just as simple as doing this and
because it has everything in the
container it just immediately and is
able to say okay we've now scaled up to
five instance so now go back I just want
to check just by refreshing and you can
see that the port has actually changed
so that's the load balancer has
automatically realized there's five
instances and just send a request to
reach of those so that's great and and
you know for simple web apps simple
flask gaps and you know other things
really useful but that build pack is
actually using and pip as we saw so I'm
going to talk a little bit later about
how we go beyond that especially at a
conference like PI data where I think
everyone knows the sort of problems you
have you try and stall numpy ER or
sought by using pip just before that
though I want to talk about those data
services so to to get access to say you
know database or no sequel service or a
message queue or something like that
it's really as simple as just you know a
few command line commands so create
service maybe I wonder Redis cloud so
that's actually a sort of third party
provider of Redis instances in the slide
and so I want to use the regicide
service the plan name is just you know
their billing plans and I want to call
it something instance name then I just
bind it to my app and that's actually
provided again in an environmental
variable to my application so and if
you're you know in Python all you need
to do is go look at the environmental
variables and see if one exists called
vcap app services and then it actually
gives you all the details so it gives
you the poor it gives you the URL the
hostname and it gives you the password
and username into that service so that's
very easy way of letting your app
actually access the service like this
and you can do interesting things like
having you know test and production and
data services so you could have a test
rider service and a production or other
services
which with different data and you could
then switch over them between them very
easily because you don't actually need
to have change any code in your
application so here are some of the
services that are available at the
moment on pivotal CF which is pivotal
sort of packaged Cloud Foundry instance
and there's other ones available on the
other different types of cloud found you
that are right there and but you know
you see interesting things I so PhD is a
Hadoop distribution when [ __ ] Cassandra
and Radisson rubbish and even Jenkins is
named as a service so you can actually
spin up Jenkins servers and using cloud
foundry and then connect to them so you
just have your workflow working like
that ok so as I said we're a PI data
conference so I kind of wanted to go
beyond just using pip to install this
kind of thing so obviously if you try to
use pip and without being able to you
know manually change the library paths
for syfy or install a fortran compiler
and all those things it's very difficult
try and do that in an automated fashion
at one remove on a server and it's gets
much harder so you know we have this
problem is solved so Conda packaging
manager enables you to do all this using
binary packages so I wanted to build a
create a build pack which is this sort
of set of instructions for Clive foundry
to say how to install the environment
necessary to run your application I
wanted to do that but for the PI data
stack so basically I've written this
it's a github and and what it does is it
first of all goes and looks at a file
called condo requirements installs all
those Condor packages and then goes and
installs the requirements text file
using pip so you know some packages
aren't on condor they don't have
packages built for them and but they are
on pi PI so you can actually go and do
both of those things at the same time so
you can even even use this to provision
your own ipython notebook server but you
know that that's at your own risk
because obviously it's open to the world
and and in fact these days I suppose if
everyone everyone's heard of the temp
NBD service nowadays if you haven't
heard of it go to it it's really
interesting they've think it's Rackspace
have
basically set up dark containers with
out by the notebook and instantly you go
to that server and it'll split up spin
up a darker container and give you
access to that darker container with I
heightened so you get your own I Payton
spawn of immediately so I probably
wouldn't recommend doing that on Cloud
Foundry right now mainly because they
you know the time sorry their security
implications of that and but what I have
been able to do in fact just since the
other day was and do something else so
what web application that uses the PI
data stack might be interesting well
yesterday there was a good talk about
spire just kind of like an hour shiny
equivalent for Python and some simple
simple syntax that actually gets you to
put different widgets together with
different plots and enables you to
interact with that very quickly and so
if you didn't see that talk yesterday
and I'm sure it's going to be on the
website the video but this is a little
spiral app that was shown in the talk
yesterday and I've actually just pushed
it to Cloud Foundry so and just make
sure I have internet here and this goes
and get stock ticker information and
just goes and then creates the the image
here the graph here there's also a table
in the background so you can change all
this sort of stuff but that's it you
know it didn't actually take me very
much to go from and the sample
application for spire which is uses
cherry pie in the back end and I
literally I think I to change one line
to actually give it the Porsche that it
needs to have to know to listen on and
then just CF push and that immediately
now is available and that's online you
can go to that URL if you want I'll
leave it up for a bit and it's actually
scaled up so scaled up to like four or
five instances so if there was like
massive load on this all of a sudden and
it wouldn't actually it wouldn't
actually be a major problem generating
these graphs very quickly so those are
the kind of interesting things that I
think you can do with cloud foundry and
suppose in the past cloud foundry has
been quite a bit sort of maybe Java and
Ruby focused and but the sort of big
thing I want to get across as Python is
now a first class citizen and I was
talking to the people who develop the
Python build pack on Friday they're
actually here in New York in the pivotal
labs office and if you have any
the feedback about that they're really
interested to hear how people are using
it so build packs are this idea that
comes from Heroku and in fact the Python
bill pack being used by a foundry the
moment is the Heroku build pack with
some minor modifications they're
interested to see what else they can do
with it and so if you have any
suggestions or you users or something
breaks and just get in touch with them
or you can get in touch with me and I'll
put you through to them okay just to
wrap up and I just wanted to talk a
little bit about why this would be
useful kind of mention these things
already as a data scientists I kind of
find I need to you know and deliver my
results to someone and often outside my
organization so it can't be you know
just sharing something on our you know
Google Drive or whatever and and you
want to make something interactive and
something nice and visually appealing
but it might be that this is quite short
lived and it might be it only needs to
be around for a few weeks maybe and so
you don't want to get into the hassle of
setting up you know the full domain and
all that sort of thing in the back end
so click foundry for me provides a
really simple way of pushing those kind
of simple straightforward things really
quickly and when you need to you can get
access to the data services in the back
end and as I said before you don't
really get locked into you know amazon
web services hikes its prices next week
but everything I've ever written is
locked into that and then I can't switch
to one of the other providers if you
want to have a go this and pivotal my
employer runs the service called pivotal
web services as a free trial on there is
just run pivotal do you can go there and
check it out from the client side and
you know you won't get access to the
back end of it but you can push
applications and there's and you know
quite an interesting pricing model for
how much that uses IBM have their
version of cloud foundry they call it
bluemix and and you can go there as well
they're doing some interesting things in
the data science space and with sort of
data science models that you're able to
sort of immediately bring into cloud
foundry any nines is a German company so
if you're interested in German data
protection laws their data centers are
purely in Germany so that's kind of
there they're an unique selling point
and
p of just announced they're going to do
something with tide friendly as well and
it's Helion thing okay as I said the
sort of materials for this talk at that
URL they're just on my blog so it's in
Houston darknet type foundry is there
the flask if you want to use flask for
data science through the tutorial called
the flask Megha Mehta tutorial for data
science and it kind of builds on this
other tutorial that's called the flask
mega tutorial and but it has a lot of
resources about you know how you could
you use flask for data science kind of
activities and what does it mean to sort
of push data in this kind of way and if
you're really interested in getting into
these kind of cloud-based applications
the kind of architecture you need the
kind of thinking you need to do about
you know my storage is ephemeral it's
going to go away my app is going to get
updated and restarted at will without me
being able to do anything about it and
these all these ideas are encapsulated
in this 12 factor apps and sort of idea
so there's like on the website you can
go down and see how you should I design
my application in order to be sort of
tired friendly these days and if you
want to learn more by type foundry the
lots of meetups all across the world and
they're kind of collided on that meetup
page that's it for me and I could talk a
little bit more about docker if anyone's
interested but I'm happy to take
questions right now first no questions
does anyone ever used cloud foundry
before it's kind of yeah
so the way this was the way to think
about this is this lives on top of
amazon web services and other providers
so for example the pivotal web services
thing that actually all that lives on
top of Amazon Web Services you never see
like AWS console you never see any of
that and but that's provided like that's
where it's running the sort of substrate
but it could also be on you know a
private cloud in your own internal data
center on like vSphere or something like
that and as a user you shouldn't ever
get to meet every need to have to
interact with AWS and Clyde foundry the
whole ideas it's for large installations
like if you're pushing one app you don't
want to spin up your tight finder you
want to use one of these hosted services
but if your organization that has a
hundred 200 applications or you may be
your building microservices and each one
of those needs to be running and you
want to do this in a tight independent
white just kind of the idea yep
yeah like this isn't you know as I said
this isn't for just set up a whole cloud
foundry instance for one application
like there's a fair amount back in that
goes into it and but people have done it
on I think something like you know maybe
there's a sort of limited that you need
a certain number of VMs to start off
with so maybe it's 10 or 15 VMs and
running all the different services so
there's like a you know a staging
manager service a droplet execution
manager and they kind of run all those
things the back end and then you need
somewhere just put the applications so
10 yeah yeah yeah this lives on
OpenStack yeah i don't i don't know yes
I think you know there's a few yeah I'm
not like deep in the weeds of that like
actually setting it up myself and but
you can definitely talk to talk two
pivotal about it and part of this sort
of thing we do with pivotal CF is
packaging those things in a really easy
way to actually install and manage so
and maybe the open source version still
needs a little bit of hand-holding and
but the package versions are a bit
easier
yeah so yeah they can be provided as a
service basically and so yeah and you
know for example weird Hadoop there as
one of the possible services so that you
know it's really providing HDFS and you
know as a storage layer but again that
you know if you're doing that in Cloud
Foundry you might want to think about
the sort of persistence of that and you
can actually create your own
user-defined service which is as simple
as you know basically giving whatever
the resource URI is and the you know
username password and just talion cloud
foundry about that and then it can give
those in the environmental variable i
talked about to any of your applications
there are any other questions if not and
then i'll stop there thank you very much
for listening